This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars and I'm in the Octagon House in San Francisco, California, with a redrofenman. So I used to work for 99% invisible and I used to live in the Bay Area and I recently came back for a visit and I wanted Roman to see this Octagon-shaped house in San Francisco. I mean, had you encountered an octagon house before? No, I mean, I must have passed this one at some point. I lived in San Francisco for eight years. I once thought this house was some sort of standalone bit of quirky architecture, but when I left the Bay Area, I realized this was not the only octagon house. Octagon-shaped houses are absolutely everywhere. There's a whole bevy of Oktagon Houses out in Long Island. There are at least a dozen Oktagon Houses in upstate New York, and if you zoom out, there's
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯，现在在加利福尼亚州旧金山的八角屋，和雷德罗芬曼在一起。我以前为《99%隐形》工作，也曾在湾区生活，最近回来探访，我想让罗曼看看旧金山这座八角形的房子。我的意思是，你之前见过八角屋吗？没有，我的意思是，我肯定在某个时候经过这里。我在旧金山住了八年。我曾经以为这座房子只是某种独立的古怪建筑，但当我离开湾区时，我意识到这并不是唯一的八角屋。八角形的房子简直随处可见。长岛有一大批八角屋。纽约州北部至少有十几座八角屋，如果你把视野拉远，还有
one in New Bedford, Massachusetts, in Connecticut, in Kansas, in Alabama, and honestly, if you search Oktagon House plus state, you will probably find one. This Oktagon House, the one out in Cal Hollow, isn't even the only Octagon House in San Francisco. There are two others. But it is the only one that's open to the public every other Sunday. It's lovely. That's the first thing.
马萨诸塞州的新贝德福德、康涅狄格州、堪萨斯州、阿拉巴马州都有，老实说，如果你搜索“八角屋”加上州名，你很可能会找到一座。这座八角屋，也就是卡尔霍洛的那座，甚至不是旧金山唯一的八角屋。还有另外两座。但它是唯一每隔一个周日就向公众开放的。它很可爱。这是第一点。
Yeah, can you do your magic? Can you describe it? It's powder blue. It is an Octagon. It has these things that where I think are the kind of the joints where the each side joins, it looks like a hint, so it looks like a giant toddler picked unfolded. Yes, it's very fish or price, it's like the vibe. This octagon house was part of a bona fide trend. In 1850s, architectural fad, people believed that octagonal houses would lead to better,
是的，你能施展你的魔法吗？你能描述一下它吗？它是粉蓝色的。它是一个八角形。它有这些东西，我想是每一面连接处的接缝，看起来像个提示，所以看起来像是一个巨大的蹒跚学步的孩子把它展开了。是的，它非常有鱼或价格感，就是那种氛围。这座八角屋是真正潮流的一部分。在1850年代，这是一种建筑时尚，人们相信八角形房屋会带来更好、
healthier, happier lives that were more in touch with the natural world. And so I was like, I've got to see if there's anything to this. I wanted to get into one of these utopian octagon houses to see what it was all about. All right, well, welcome toopian octagon houses to see what it was all about. All right, well welcome to the Octagon House. The technical name for this Octagon House is the McElroy House because a family named McElroy built the house when they moved out west. And then they decide they're going to build this new fad of a home, an octagon home, and you'll find out more about that when you go in there.
更健康、更快乐的生活，与自然世界更亲近。所以我当时想，我得看看这到底是怎么回事。我想进入这些乌托邦式的八角屋，看看它到底是什么。好吧，欢迎来到八角屋。这座八角屋的正式名称是麦克尔罗伊宅邸，因为一个叫麦克尔罗伊的家庭在搬到西部时建造了这座房子。然后他们决定建造这种新的住宅时尚，即八角形住宅，当你进去时，你会发现更多关于它的信息。
But here's what I learned about the Octagon House Fad once I went in there. Very little. Do you know anything more about the Octagon House Fad? The museum contents are colonial and federalists. The exterior is 1860 what? And so nothing in this was originally part of the Octagon. Is there any one or two things? No.
但我进去后学到的是关于八角屋热潮的什么呢？很少。你对八角屋热潮还有更多了解吗？博物馆里的藏品是殖民地和联邦主义时期的。外观是1860年的，什么？所以这里面没有任何东西最初是八角屋的一部分。有一两件东西吗？没有。
Okay. No, absolutely not. It turns out that the McElroy Octagon House is run by a group called the Colonial Dames of America. And the purpose of the group is to preserve colonial and federalist history. So now you're in colonial times here, up through 1787. And the colonial dames just so happened to buy this octagon-shaped house when it was condemned in 1952.
好吧。不，绝对没有。事实证明，麦克尔罗伊八角屋是由一个叫“美国殖民地贵妇”的组织管理的。该组织的目的是保护殖民地和联邦主义的历史。所以你现在身处殖民时代，一直到1787年。而殖民地贵妇们恰好在1952年这座房子被宣布为危房时买下了它。
It cost them one dollar. They thought it was cool, and so they just filled it with their own historical archive, which has absolutely nothing to do with the octagon house or the era it was built in. In here is a lot of China from when the Martí de Lafayette returned to the United States from 1824 to 1825. And so I'm sorry not to sound dense but like is the Octagon House considered Federalist or Colonialist like what is the style? Well it's neither the house is neither. The colonial dams were so nice and sweet and I was a jerk on a single-minded quest. So this visit was very frustrating to me because every time I asked about octagons, I was
它花了一美元。她们觉得它很酷，于是就用她们自己的历史档案填满了它，这些档案与八角屋或它建造的时代毫无关系。这里面有很多马蒂·德·拉斐特从1824年到1825年从美国返回时的瓷器。我很抱歉，听起来不想显得迟钝，但八角屋被认为是联邦主义还是殖民主义的？它的风格是什么？嗯，都不是，房子两者都不是。殖民地贵妇们非常友善和甜美，而我是一个一心一意追求目标的混蛋。所以这次访问让我非常沮丧，因为每次我问关于八角形的问题时，我都被
shown an oil painting of George Washington or a collection of old grocery lists and letters that were written by the members of the Continental Congress. We have 55, the original signatures of 55, the 56 signers of the Declaration of Independence. We can talk about that. But there among the teacups and the calligraphed signatures and the colonial era, Brickabrac, the dams did have a copy of this book called The Octagon House, a home for all.
展示了一幅乔治·华盛顿的油画，或者是一堆由大陆会议成员写的旧购物清单和信件。我们有55个，是《独立宣言》56位签署人中55位的原始签名。我们可以谈谈那个。但在茶杯、书法签名和殖民时代的杂物中，贵妇们确实有一本名为《八角屋，一个属于所有人的家》的书。
Because just like for going carbohydrates or vampire erotica, or throwing out whatever doesn't spark joy, this fad also started with a book written by a man named Orson S. Fowler. This is the book he wrote that popularized octagon houses nationwide. But was he like part of a movement or is he just sort of some random... I think he's part somewhat of a movement and I'm not knowledgeable enough, but you know, but we have interesting things here too, like we have this fire bucket. When we have the kids here, we do a bucket brigade.
因为就像戒掉碳水化合物或吸血鬼色情文学，或者扔掉任何不能激发快乐的东西一样，这种时尚也始于一个名叫奥森·S·福勒的人写的一本书。这就是他写的在全国普及八角屋的书。但他是一个运动的一部分，还是只是一个随机的……我想他多少是运动的一部分，我没有足够的知识，但你知道，我们这里也有有趣的东西，比如我们有这个消防桶。当孩子们在这里时，我们会进行水桶接力。
Okay, so the dams were clearly not gonna be the ones to explain why there were octagon houses all over the United States or what or some followers deal was. And honestly, there wasn't a lot out there to explain it. Yeah, it's not often that I get asked to talk about octagon houses, so I was excited to get your request. Irene Chang is an architectural historian and a professor
好吧，所以贵妇们显然不是那种能解释为什么美国到处都是八角屋，或者奥森·福勒到底是怎么回事的人。老实说，外面没有太多解释它的东西。是的，我不常被要求谈论八角屋，所以我很高兴收到你的请求。艾琳·张是一位建筑历史学家和教授，
at California College of the Arts. She wrote her dissertation on the Octagon House FAD. But I also think, you know, we can't just write it off as a FAD, because what I find really fascinating is that, again, hundreds, if not thousands, of people took up his idea and actually tried it out and built off the gone houses. And the other reason the American octagonal house fad
在加州艺术学院。她写了关于八角屋热潮的论文。但我也认为，你知道，我们不能仅仅把它写成一种时尚，因为我发现真正令人着迷的是，同样，成百上千，如果不是成千上万的人采纳了他的想法，并真正尝试建造了八角屋。美国八角屋热潮难以被忽视的另一个原因是
is hard to write off is because it became the physical embodiment of all sorts of new ideas and new values that were really radical for their time, and many of them were inspired by Orson Fowler's very specific ideology. Orson Fowler was not a builder or an architect. He was able to publish a book on Octagon Houses because he was a publisher. Fowler's publishing house, Fowler and Wells actually published Walt Whitman's Leaves of Grass. They had a kind of publishing empire and they published books on things
因为它成为了各种新思想和新价值观的物理体现，这些思想和价值观在当时是非常激进的，其中许多受到奥森·福勒非常具体的意识形态的启发。奥森·福勒不是建筑商或建筑师。他之所以能出版一本关于八角屋的书，是因为他是一位出版商。福勒的出版社“福勒与威尔斯”实际上出版了沃尔特·惠特曼的《草叶集》。他们拥有某种出版帝国，他们出版关于诸如
like How to Write, How to Do Business, How to Behave. These were, functionally, early self-help books. There's a subsession starting in the sort of 1840s and really expanding the 50s with self-cultivation, self-understanding. To give you an idea of how new and how huge this was, in 1841 Noah Webster added 67 new words to his dictionary that began with the prefix self. And that's what Fowler really does an amazing job of is capitalizing on this obsession with self-improvement, self-cultivation. This was connected to a wave of social movements on the 1840s, like temperance and abstinence and abolition and abolition of child labor and women's suffrage, there was this desire to remedy the plight of the common man, to improve society by improving individuals, which Fowler was extremely invested
如何写作、如何做生意、如何举止的书籍。这些在功能上是早期的自助书籍。从1840年代开始，并在50年代真正扩展，人们对自我修养、自我理解有一种痴迷。为了让你了解这有多新、多巨大，1841年诺亚·韦伯斯特在他的字典中增加了67个以“自我”为前缀的新词。这就是福勒真正做得非常出色的一点，即利用这种对自我提升、自我修养的痴迷。这与1840年代的一波社会运动有关，如禁酒、节欲、废奴、废除童工和妇女选举权，人们有一种改善普通人困境的愿望，通过改善个人来改善社会，福勒对此非常投入，
in, not only as a publisher, but by his primary trade. The thing he was most well known for, because Orson Fowler was perhaps America's most famous fornologist. You know, fornology, that's this kind of, you know, comical pseudoscience of being able to read a person's characteristics or personality based on the shape of their head. Fornologists like Fowler believed that certain lumps on your head corresponded to certain personality traits.
不仅作为出版商，而且通过他的主要职业。他最出名的事情，因为奥森·福勒也许是美国最著名的颅相学家。你知道，颅相学，这是一种，你知道，滑稽的伪科学，能够根据一个人的头部形状来解读其特征或个性。像福勒这样的颅相学家认为，你头上的某些肿块对应于某些性格特征。
Like certain bumps could tell you how cautious or secretive or mirthful you were. And phrenology, which has been completely and entirely disproven, it is important to note, was applied in all kinds of very racist ways. You know, most American phrenologists that you read, including Fowler, say incredibly racist things about the capacity of African-Americans and other non-white groups about their capacity for improvement in their instinctive and innate traits. Fowler was used as a pseudoscientific way
比如某些凸起可以告诉你你是多么谨慎、隐秘或快乐。而颅相学，已经被完全彻底地反驳了，这一点很重要，它被以各种非常种族主义的方式应用。你知道，你读到的大多数美国颅相学家，包括福勒，都对非裔美国人和其他非白人群体的能力，以及他们改进的能力和本能的先天特征说了极其种族主义的话。福勒被用作一种伪科学的方式
to explain why women were stupid, and people of color were inferior and Jews were evil. And Orson Fowler was actually considered pretty progressive in his time as a feminist and an abolitionist, although it was all from this very paternalistic perspective, like, oh, these poor people in their mischaping heads. So this is all to say, what little I knew about phrenology, I thought it was exclusively the purview of ghoulish race scientists with head measuring calipers. And that is true, the racist history is very much there.
来解释为什么女性是愚蠢的，有色人种是低等的，犹太人是邪恶的。而奥森·福勒在当时实际上被认为是相当进步的女性主义者和废奴主义者，尽管这一切都源于这种非常家长式的视角，比如，哦，这些可怜的人，他们的头型不好。所以这一切都是说，关于颅相学我所知甚少，我以为它完全是那些拿着头部测量卡尺的恐怖种族科学家的专属领域。这是真的，种族主义的历史确实存在。
What I was surprised to learn about phonology was that it was part of this burgeoning world of self-improvement. In its time, it was almost treated like astrology or anyogram tests. Phonology was pretty popular. Orson Fowler and his brother had an office in Manhattan, and it was really much more of a showroom slash museum called the Phrenological Cabinet, and it became one of the most popular attractions in New York City.
关于颅相学，我惊讶地发现它竟然是这个新兴的自我提升世界的一部分。在当时，它几乎被当作占星术或九型人格测试来对待。颅相学相当流行。奥森·福勒和他的兄弟在曼哈顿有一个办公室，它实际上更像是一个陈列室兼博物馆，被称为“颅相学内阁”，它成为了纽约市最受欢迎的景点之一。
It showcased hundreds of Phrenological portraits of famous people, so you could giggle and gawk at how unusually large the lumps for secretiveness and destructiveness were on Aaron Burr's skull, and lots of people went there to get their own heads read. You know, you encounter all kinds of writers referring to going to New York, getting a phonological reading, or ordinary people in their diaries mentioning that they went to a phonological lecture and got a reading. Employers sought out employees with particular franological profiles.
它展示了数百幅名人的颅相学肖像，所以你可以咯咯地笑，盯着阿伦·伯尔头骨上那些异常大的隐秘和破坏性的肿块，很多人去那里解读自己的头部。你知道，你会遇到各种作家提到去纽约，进行颅相学解读，或者普通人在日记中提到他们去听了颅相学讲座并进行了解读。雇主们寻找具有特定颅相学特征的员工。
Some even requested readings from the Fowlers as a reference. Women came up with hairstyles that would show off their more flattering franological features. And Fowler and Wells published the American franological journal. So I think it's really telling, for example, that on the cover of their journal, the American franological journal, the motto is, know thyself. And there were not a lot of tools for doing that.
有些人甚至要求福勒兄弟进行解读作为参考。女性想出了能展示她们更讨人喜欢的颅相学特征的发型。福勒和威尔斯出版了《美国颅相学杂志》。所以我认为这非常能说明问题，例如，在他们的杂志《美国颅相学杂志》的封面上，座右铭是“认识你自己”。而当时并没有多少工具可以做到这一点。
This was before the invention of talk therapy. This is before Freud. So people were aching to know more about themselves and improve themselves. And at the time, chronology fit right in with all of Fowler's proto-self-help literature. In the hands of Fowler and his family, you know, what they were really selling is this kind of method of knowing yourself, knowing your own capacities and proclivities, and then using that self-knowledge to strategically improve yourself. Strangely, it was phrenology that led Fowler to architecture. In all of his
这是在谈话疗法发明之前。这是在弗洛伊德之前。所以人们渴望更多地了解自己并提升自己。在当时，颅相学正好符合福勒所有的原始自助文学。在福勒和他的家人手中，你知道，他们真正销售的是这种认识你自己、了解自己的能力和倾向的方法，然后利用这种自我知识来战略性地提升自己。奇怪的是，正是颅相学将福勒引向了建筑。在他所有的
franological observations, there were two particular headlumps that interested him. There was, supposedly, a lump for inhabitiveness, which is basically the desire to nest, and a lump for constructiveness, which was related to the desire to build a house. Fowler essentially came to the conclusion that all men should discover the pleasure of building their own home to meet their own particular unique needs. And Fowler decided that the best, most beautiful, most healthy, most cost-efficient way for everyone to build their own home would be to build a house in the shape of an octagon. And according to his book, here's why. Most fundamentally, if you have a house with a lot of sides, you can add more windows
颅相学观察中，有两个特定的头部肿块引起了他的兴趣。据说有一个“居住性”肿块，基本上是筑巢的欲望，还有一个“建设性”肿块，与建造房屋的欲望有关。福勒基本上得出的结论是，所有人都应该发现建造自己的家园以满足自己特定独特需求的乐趣。福勒认为，每个人建造自己家园最好、最美、最健康、最经济的方式就是建造一座八角形的房子。根据他的书，原因如下。最根本的是，如果你有一座有很多面的房子，你可以在所有面上增加更多的窗户，
to all the sides and get more light. You can look out of all those windows and feel more of a connection with nature. Give me a beautiful landscape and an elevated side. This also guarantees a fresh, dry atmosphere. And because the house approximated a circle, air was supposed to circulate well through it. He's also obsessed like many 19th century domestic reformers with ventilation. For every human being requires a copious and constant supply of this commodity. So indispensable, not merely to human comfort,
获得更多的光线。你可以从所有这些窗户向外看，感受到与自然的更多联系。给我一个美丽的风景和一个高处。这也保证了新鲜、干燥的空气。而且因为房子近似于圆形，空气应该能在其中很好地循环。他也像许多19世纪的家庭改革者一样痴迷于通风。因为每个人都需要充足且持续的这种商品供应。如此不可或缺，不仅对人类的舒适，
but even existence. The octagon was supposed to be practical, more affordable to the common man. We're supposed to look very humble, without much fancy adornment or décor. Tyler says ornament is very expensive, and shouldn't be the primary concern. Instead, you should focus on function, health, efficiency.
甚至对生存而言。八角形应该是实用的，对普通人来说更负担得起。我们应该看起来非常谦逊，没有太多华丽的装饰或装潢。福勒说装饰非常昂贵，不应该是首要考虑因素。相反，你应该关注功能、健康、效率。
This sounds like the rationale of 20th century modernism, but this is the mid-1800s. Like, Orbusier wouldn't even be born for a few more decades at the time that Fowler was developing his ideas. And the biggest one was like, design for all. The octagon was supposed to be economical and efficient. Now since a given link to botcon wall, one closed one fifth more space
这听起来像是20世纪现代主义的理由，但这可是19世纪中期。就像，在福勒发展他的想法时，勒·柯布西耶还要几十年才出生。而最大的一个是“为所有人设计”。八角形应该是经济和高效的。现在，由于给定的八角墙长度，封闭的空间比同样长度的墙在方形形状中多出五分之一，当然，你可以用同样大小的墙花五分之一的钱。我不太明白，但这也许是我那小小的女人头骨的问题。它充满了所有这些图表。就像准数学图表。然后他比较了数字，显示八角形效率高得多。
than the same link to wall and a square shape, of course, you can have the same size wall for one fifth less money. I don't quite get it, but that's perhaps my tiny little woman's skull. It's filled with all of these diagrams. Like quasi-mathematical diagrams. And then he compares the numbers and shows that the octagon is far more efficient.
福勒声称他的房子在体力消耗方面会节省能源，比如你不需要走那么多路。一个庞大而活跃的家庭每年在八角形房子里比在方形房子里要节省多少步啊。正如他指出的，这对家里的女性尤为重要。她可以节省她的脚步，节省她的体力，这样她基本上可以生出更强壮的孩子。在不方便的房子里，多少恐惧和坏脾气，以及疲惫和疾病，不仅邪恶，而且通常，通过不断地激怒母亲，
Fowler claimed his house would save energy in terms of physical exertion, like you wouldn't have to walk as much. What a vast number of steps will the octagon save a large and stirring family annually over a square. It was, as he notes, especially important for the women of the house. She can save her steps and save her strength so that she can bear stronger children, essentially. How much frightfulness and ill temper as well as exhaustion and sickness in unhandy house occasions, nor does evil and here, it often generally, by perpetually irritating mothers,
使孩子们的脾气变坏，甚至在出生前就变坏，从而使整个家庭天生性格不好。所以这就是我们开始进入关于八角形更疯狂的主张的地方。因为福勒基本上认为这座房子将是伟大的改革者。它将把女性从家务中解放出来。它会让每个人的心情更好。它会有一个大的主客厅供大家闲逛，这样你就可以保持家庭单位的完整，
sours the tempers of their children, even before birth, thus rendering the whole family bad disposition to bind nature. So this is where we start to get into the more wild claims about the octagon. Because fellers basically like this house will be the great reformer. It will liberate women from chores. It will put everyone in a better mood. It will have this big main parlor to hang out in so that you can keep the family unit intact
这样就没人需要出去在酒吧里社交了。你知道，城市里正在出现的这些空间，男人可以在那里和其他男人做出不体面的行为。所以这表面上是关于禁酒和男人在酒吧里喝醉和吵闹。但这也是关于行为和礼仪，因为福勒真的痴迷于这种适当性行为的想法，也就是老式的求爱观念，
so no one has to go out and socialize in bars. You know, these spaces in the city that are emerging where men can behave in unseemly ways with other men. So that's ostensibly about temperance and men getting drunk and rowdy in bars. But it's also about behavior and propriety, because Fowler was really obsessed with this idea of proper sexuality, which is to say the old-fashioned notion of courtship,
福勒想象这会在八角形美丽的客厅里很好地展开。所以他写到客厅是培养这种适当性行为的空间。然后似乎毫无征兆地，在八角屋书的中间，福勒开始谈论关于水果的长篇大论，不同种类的水果，最好的水果，你会遇到这些段落，他喋喋不休地谈论苹果。你会想，你为什么这么痴迷于苹果？好吧，这个论点我真的很喜欢。福勒声称住在八角形里
which Fowler imagined would play out well in the beautiful parlor of the octagon. So he writes about the parlor as a space for the cultivation of this proper sexuality. And then seemingly, out of nowhere, in the middle of the octagon book, Fowler starts going on this long tangent about fruit, different kinds of fruit, the best kinds of fruit, and you come across these passages where he goes on and on about apples. And you're like, why are you so obsessed with apples? Okay, this argument I really love. Fowler claims that living in an octagon shape
会更有利于当时被称为素食主义的激进边缘运动。你知道，对于农民来说，苹果是一种可以长期储存的水果，所以你可以在冬天和春天吃到新鲜水果。在福勒的愿景中，理想的八角屋将完全由混凝土制成，当然，你自己混合砾石，以了解建造的乐趣。这意味着你将拥有这个巨大的水泥地窖。
would be more conducive to what was then the radical fringy movement known as vegetarianism. You know, for farmers, apples were a fruit that could be stored for a long time so you could have like fresh fruit in the winter and into the spring. In Fowler's vision, the ideal octagon house would be made entirely out of concrete, and you'd mix your own gravel yourself, of course, to know the pleasure of building. And it would mean you'd have this big, big cement cellar.
这个地下室在各方面都比我们现在的坑洞地窖优越得多。这个砾石地窖有能力保持非常非常冷，而这还是在制冷技术出现之前的日子。所以，冷藏可能有助于你，用福勒的话说，用浆果及其汁液代替牛奶和黄油。因此，房子变成了一种假体，有助于支持这些系统和过程，通过这些系统和过程，你知道，你可以喂养身体，健康的食物会使它更强壮，就像房子的布局有助于促进某种高效的运动一样。另一个愿景是，他所有的哲学都会在八角形的形状中融合，八角形住宅将成为终极的自我提升机器。福勒在1853年出版了他的书《八角屋，一个属于所有人的家》，它成为了
How incomparably superior in every respect this basement to our present pit hole cellars. respect this basement to our present pit hole sellers. This gravel seller had the capacity to get and stay very, very cold and this isn't the days before refrigeration. So, the cold storage might help you in the words of Fowler. Substitute berries and their juice in place of milk and butter. And so, the house becomes a prosthetic that helps support these systems and processes by which, you know, you can feed the body, healthy food that will make it stronger, just as the layout of the house helps facilitate kind of efficient movement. Another vision was that all of his philosophies would coalesce in the shape of an octagon, and the octagon home would become the ultimate self-improvement machine. Fowler published his book, The Octagon House, A Home for All, in 1853, and it became a
轰动。数百座八角屋开始在全国各地涌现。甚至可能有数千座八角屋。从来没有关于建造了多少座的官方统计。在堪萨斯州甚至有一个完全由八角屋组成的素食废奴主义公社。它被称为“八角城”。那个乌托邦实验最终只持续了几个月。
sensation. Hundreds of octagon houses started popping up all over the country. It could have even been thousands of octagon houses. There was never an official count of how many got built. There was even a vegetarian abolitionist commune made entirely of octagon houses in Kansas. It was called octagon city. That utopian experiment ultimately only lasted a few months.
但重点是，福勒的想法流行起来并随着八角屋传播开来。这很滑稽，因为在福勒写这本书的时候，他所有的断言或多或少都是猜测。他在写这本书解释它们为什么这么好、为什么工作得这么好时，正在建造他的第一座八角屋。而福勒自己的八角屋并不是他表面上提倡的那种简单朴素的房子。福勒建造了一座巨大的60个房间的八角形豪宅，
But the point is, Fowler's ideas caught on and spread with the octagon house. Which is hilarious, because at the time that Fowler was writing this book, all of his assertions were more or less guesses. He was building his very first Octagon House at the same time that he was writing this book about why they were so great and why they worked so well. And Fowler's own Octagon House wasn't a simple modest house like the ones he ostensibly advocated for. Fowler constructed a massive 60-room octagon-shaped mansion
在纽约州菲什基尔。他实际上如此彻底地致力于建造这座八角屋，以至于沃尔特·惠特曼不得不接管出版社。福勒认为他的八角屋将是他的杰作，证明他关于最佳生活的理论是正确的。它被广泛嘲笑为“福勒的愚行”。几年里，福勒能够享受他
in Fishkill, New York. And he actually devoted himself so thoroughly to building this octagon house that Walt Whitman had to take over the publishing house. Fowler thought his octagon house would be his showpiece, his proof that his theories for optimal living were right. It was widely mocked as Fowler's folly. For a few years, Fowler was able to enjoy the fruits
劳动的成果。他住在他的八角屋里，邀请朋友来吃素食，讲授颅相学，并为《颅相学杂志》写作。但在1857年的经济大萧条中，八角热潮开始放缓，福勒本人也陷入了困境。他租出了他的八角豪宅，它被改建成了一家寄宿公寓。
of his labor. He lived in his Octagon house and invited friends over for vegetarian meals and lectured about frenology and wrote for the franological journal. But in the economic depression of 1857, the Octagon Fad started to slow down, and Fowler himself fell on hard times. He rented out his Octagon mansion, and it was converted into a boarding house.
在那里，它成为了大规模伤寒爆发的现场，部分原因是污水池渗漏穿过了福勒所谓的优越的砾石墙，福勒的愚行在1880年被遗弃，福勒于1887年去世，房子在10年后被拆除。那真是一座房子。还有什么尘世的住所能比这更美丽、更宏伟、更方便或更舒适呢。好吧，所以福勒的福勒是一个失败，但这么多八角屋仍然存在，大概是由那些能比奥森·福勒更好地混合混凝土的人建造的。既然福勒的想法显然是胡说八道，那为什么八角屋会传播得如此广泛
Where it became the scene of a massive typhoid outbreak, partially because of a cesspool seepage through Fowler's supposedly superior gravel walls, Fowler's folly was abandoned by 1880, and Fowler died in 1887, and the house was torn down 10 years later. That's such a house. What earthly habitation could be more beautiful, more imposing, more convenient, or more comfortable. Okay, so Fowler's Fowler was a bust, but so many octagons are still around, presumably made by people who could mix their concrete better than Orson Fowler could. And so Fowler's ideas were so obviously bunk, then why did Octagon house is spread so widely
以那种方式呢？我推断住在八角形里一定有什么东西。我一生中大部分时间都在房子里长大。迈克尔·恩巴迪是纽约州欧文顿阿莫尔·斯坦纳宅邸的看护人。它巨大、令人印象深刻。也许是美国最著名的八角屋，离福勒的愚行如果还在的话所在的地方不远。离奥森·斯奎尔·福勒在纽约菲什基尔建造他的家的地方的物理距离，
in the way they did? I reasoned there had to be something to living in an Octagon. And I've grown up in the house very much part of my life throughout my entire life. Michael Embardi is a caretaker of the armor Steiner House in Irvington, New York. It's massive, impressive. Perhaps the most famous octagon house in America, and not far from where Fowler's Folly would be if it were still standing. The physical proximity to where Orson Square Fowler built his home in Fischke in New York,
确实我们离那里相对较近。所以阿莫尔·斯坦纳宅邸，我想，将是我对八角屋到底是什么的真实观察，特别是迈克尔与这座房子有如此个人的联系。我想那是约瑟夫·隆巴迪。他是阿莫尔·斯坦纳八角屋的主人。我在过去43年里断断续续地在这座房子里工作。所以我当时想，太好了，也许迈克尔感受到了福勒所吹捧的一些好处，比如光线、空气、美丽和活力。也许这座房子真的能说明
it's true that we're relatively close to where that was. So the armor Steiner House, I thought, would be my genuine look into what an octagon house is all about, especially because Michael had such a personal connection with the house. I thought there's Joseph Lombardi. He's the owner of the armor Steiner Octagon House. I have worked on the house on and off for the past 43 years. So I was like, great, maybe Michael felt some of the benefits that Fowler was touting, like the light and the air and the beauty and the vitality. Maybe this house could really speak
福勒在追求什么。结果，再一次，绝对没有。这很有趣，因为它采用了福勒最初的想法，并以各种方式将其颠倒过来。这几乎就像是在划掉他的概念，即“少即是多”是不对的。这不是关于还原性的简单。这不是关于效率。这是关于奢华的满足。阿莫尔·斯坦纳宅邸几乎是
to what Fowler was getting at. And it turned out, once again, absolutely not. It's funny because it is taking Fowler's original idea and kind of turning it on end in every way. It was almost like exing out his concepts that it's not about lesses more. It's not about reductive simplicity. It's not about efficiency. It's about lavish fulfillment. The armor Steiner House is almost the opposite
福勒住宅的对立面。基本上，这座房子最初是一座简单的传统福勒住宅，但在1872年，约瑟夫·斯坦纳，一位非常成功的茶叶商人，在曼哈顿拥有76家咖啡和茶馆，搬进了这座房子并彻底改造了它。约瑟夫·斯坦纳把整个房子漆成了粉红色。他增加了一层楼，并在顶部加了一个带有周围门户窗户的巨大圆顶。
of a Fowler home. Basically, the house started out as a simple traditional Fowler house, but then in 1872, Joseph Steiner, a very successful team merchant who had 76 coffee and tea houses in Manhattan moved into this house and totally redid it. Joseph Steiner painted the whole thing pink. He added a floor, he topped it with a gigantic dome with portal windows all around it.
最值得注意的是，约瑟夫·斯坦纳只是混合了来自所有不同时代的各种形式的装饰。你知道，维多利亚时代是对不同时期不同设计的奢华融合。事实上，有一个完整的埃及房间。我们现在在埃及复兴室。哇。以埃及复兴风格装饰，它尽可能地实现了。它有一架定制装饰有狮身人面像的钢琴。墙壁上覆盖着象形文字。天花板上画着2000颗星星，迈克尔亲自费力地重新粉刷了它们。
And most notably, Joseph Steiner just mixed it up with all different forms of ornamentation from across all different eras. You know, Victorian eras is a lavish incorporation of different designs from different periods. In fact, there is an entire Egyptian room. Here we are in the Egyptian Revival Room. Wow. Decorated in the Egyptian Revival style, it's fully realized as it could be. It has a piano that's custom-decorated with sphinxes on it. The walls are covered in hieroglyphs. The ceiling is painted with 2,000 stars, which Michael painstakingly repainted himself.
尽我们所能，我们试图在每个房间里把一切恢复到1872年的样子。这确实非常酷。但这确实意味着没有办法知道这座八角屋在最初建造时是什么样子。如果它遵循奥森·福勒的平面图并做了福勒所说的所有事情，再一次，这与麦克尔罗伊宅邸和殖民地贵妇们没什么不同，阿莫尔·斯坦纳宅邸恰好是一个属于另一个时代的八角形容器。所以也许福勒的八角形并没有做他所说的任何事情。是的，我认为他有点夸大了这两件事，或者为颅相学的想法和八角形房屋的想法使用了一种推销员平台。
To the best of our ability, we've tried in every room to restore everything to exactly the way it was in 1872. It is admittedly so cool. But it means there's really no way of knowing how this octagon house looked when it was originally constructed. If it followed Orson Fowler's floor plan and did all the things that Fowler said it would do, once again, not unlike the McOroy House and the Colonial Dames, the Armour Steiner House just so happens to be an octagon-shaped vessel for another time period. So maybe Fowler's octagons didn't do much of anything, he said they would. Yeah, I think he was kind of overselling both of these things, or using a kind of salesman platform for both the idea of fornology and of octagonal houses.
我的意思是，我认为绝对有，你知道，一个合理的理由认为福勒的八角屋想法是一种蛇油类产品。但关于蛇油的事情是，中国水蛇油恰好是欧米茄-3脂肪酸的极好来源。这是真的，去查查吧。事实证明，现代八角屋，因为有现代八角屋，有一个福勒无法完全预料到的好处。我们相信我们是这些结构的世界领导者。我们把它们运往全球各地。我们在所有50个州都有德尔塔康，我想还有近30个国家。史蒂夫·林顿是德尔塔康公司的总裁。他们制造预制房屋，运往全国和世界各地，它们
I mean, I think there's definitely, you know, a kind of legitimate case to be made that fowlers octagon house idea was a kind of snake oil type product. But the thing about snake oil is that Chinese water snake oil just so happens to be an excellent source of omega-3 fatty acids. It's real, look it up. And it turns out that modern octagon houses, because there are modern octagon houses, have a benefit that Fowler couldn't fully anticipate. We believe we are the world leader in these structures. We ship them all over the globe. We've got Delta coms in all 50 states, and I think almost 30 countries. Steve Linton is the president of Delta combs Inc. They make prefabricated homes that they ship all over the country in the world, and they
都是八角形形状的迭代。你知道，八角屋在某种意义上是真的，但圆形或圆形的家或全景家通常是我们描述它的方式。德尔塔康并没有受到奥森·福勒理论的启发。事实上，史蒂夫在我告诉他之前没有听说过奥森·福勒。德尔塔康始于1968年，他们受到了当时周围发生的测地线圆顶热潮的启发，因为他们离黑山学院曾经所在的地方不远，那是巴克敏斯特·富勒曾经教书和建造圆顶的地方。而且你有
are all iterations of an octagon shape. You know, an octagon house is true in some sense, but a circular or a round home or a panoramic home is often how we describe it. Deltek was not inspired by the theories of Orson Fowler. In fact, Steve had not heard of Orson Fowler until I told him about him. Deltek started out in 1968, and they were inspired by the geodesic dome crays
像巴克敏斯特·富勒这样的人，你在这个北卡罗来纳州西部特别有这种圆形住宅建设的温床。这些住宅应该增加空气循环，建造起来更具成本效益，
that was happening all around them, because they're not far from where Black Mountain College used to be, which is where Buckminster Fuller used to teach, and build domes. And you've which is where Buckminster Fuller used to teach and build domes. And you've got people like Buckminster Fuller, and you've sort of got this hotbed of round-home construction here in Western North Carolina specifically. These homes were supposed to increase air circulation and be more cost-efficient
有更多的窗户和光线。这听起来非常像福勒。因为窗户轻轻地包裹着你，感觉就像你住在外面一样。如果德尔塔康没有意外发现他们全景住宅的一个巨大好处，它们可能只会保持古怪和福勒风格。我希望我能说在开始时有一个宏伟的计划，我希望我能说在开始时有一个宏伟的计划来创造一个抗飓风的家，创造一个能在气候变化中有所作为的家，但这更多的是一种进化。你知道，人们最初建造德尔塔住宅是因为惊人的景色以及它给他们带来的感觉。就这么简单。随着时间的推移，我们一次又一次地看到，风暴过后，德尔塔住宅是留下的那些。房子被撕裂，屋顶像纸一样被吹走。什么能抵御每小时140英里的风？这座房子可以。它实际上被设计成在飓风中保持完整。
to build with more windows and light. It was all sounding very foul or ask. It almost feels like you're living outside because of the way the windows gently wrap around you. And they might have just stayed quirky and foul or ask. If Deltech hadn't accidentally discovered a huge benefit of their panoramic houses. I wish I could say there was this grand plan I wish I could say there was this grand plan back at the beginning to create a hurricane resistance home to create a home that could make a difference with climate change, but it was much more of an evolution. You know, people built a Delta home originally because of the amazing view and how it made
但很简单，强风在圆形房子周围呼啸而过。它们不会压在大的平坦侧面上。德尔塔康开始使气候韧性成为他们的专长。对。我们正在研究的一大重点是如何设计一个能抵御每小时225英里风速的家？当然，奥森·福勒没有预料到气候危机。他没有考虑飓风，但在福勒介绍他的八角形计划之前，他写道，如果它暴露在冬天的强风中会怎样？
them feel. It was as simple as that. And over time, we saw again and again, storm after storm, deltex were the ones that were left standing. House's torn apart roofs blown away like paper. What could survive 140 miles per hour wins? This house can. It was actually designed to remain intact during a hurricane.
它们不是令人振奋和健康的吗？然而，一个计划很快就会被提出，它将使你能够藐视它们，同时享受夏天的微风。事实证明，坏掉的时钟确实一天准两次。当我走出前门时，我无法分辨风向我们吹来的方向。我走离房子。我知道我必须找到一种方法去看一座真正的福勒住宅，而且它必须是一座小型私人住宅，而不是一座被改建成致力于另一个时代的住宅博物馆的房子。所以当一个朋友告诉我他开车经过纽约州北部高速公路边的一座八角屋时，我想我应该去敲门并试着和他们谈谈。看看他们的八角屋是否真的让他们生活得更好、更有效率。我简直不敢相信我有多幸运，住在房子里的人恰好是鲍勃和拉里。这是一个很棒的房子，正如你将看到的，从内部看。我一直是一个会住在阁楼或改建的白色城堡之类地方的人。看起来正常的房子让我觉得有点无聊。
But very simply, high winds whip around a rounded house. can. It was actually designed to remain intact during a hurricane. But very simply, high winds whip around a rounded house. They don't press on the big flat sides. And Deltech began to make climate resilience their specialty. Right. One of the big things we're looking at is how can we design a home to withstand 225-mAh wind speeds? Of course, Orson Fowler was not anticipating the climate crisis. He wasn't thinking about hurricanes, but before Fowler introduces his octagon plan, he writes, and what if it is exposed to winter's plink winds?
鲍勃和拉里在他们的八角屋里住了10年。它是奶油黄色的，是一个朴素的两层楼。线条和一切都非常简单。令我极其高兴的是，鲍勃和拉里非常了解奥森·福勒的现代生活八角形理论。他们没有做任何改变房子结构的事情。它实际上从最初建造时就保持完整，他们可以确定日期，因为他们在厨房的墙上发现了一个铭文。如果你看它，上面写着“斯托克波特，哥伦比亚县，1860年11月9日，一个晴朗凉爽的日子，林肯亚伯拉罕当选”。这是写在窗户上最初的仿饰面上的。
Are they not bracing and healthy? Yet a plan will soon be proposed which will enable you to defy them, yet enjoy summer's balmy braces. It turns out a broken clock is indeed right twice. When I walk out the front door, I can't tell which way the wind is blowing on us. I walk away from the house. I knew that I had to find a way to see a genuine fowler home and then it had to be some small private house, not one that had been turned into a house museum devoted to another era. And so when a friend told me he drove by an octagon house on the side of the
所以我们知道房子早于1860年。哇。那真的很酷。那真的很酷。那真的很酷。鲍勃和拉里的客厅兼餐厅在功能上是一个巨大的、未分割的客厅。你可以看到光线在一天中从房子的所有八个角落流进来。
highway in upstate New York, I figured I would just go knock on the door and try to talk to them. To see if their octagon house really made them live better and more efficiently. And I cannot believe how lucky I was that the people living in the house just so happened to be Bob and Larry. It's a great house, as you'll see, from the inside. And I was always the kind of person that would live in a loft or a converted white castle or something like that. Normal looking houses kind of bore me.
他们的客厅郁郁葱葱，充满了茁壮成长的植物，甚至还有一些鲍勃培育的盆景树。也许是参数压力，也许是光线，但我们可以拿一根扫帚棍插进土里，它就会发芽。我的意思是，这里什么都能长。我不知道是什么原因，但我们很少失去一株植物。诚然，住在八角形里的一个缺点是鲍勃和拉里的很多壁橱形状奇怪且很小。你可以看到壁橱是三角形的。是的，这是一个储物柜。你确实很好地利用了这一点。这是一个非常奇怪的空间。是的，但你知道我们是奇怪的人。
Bob and Larry have lived in their Octagon House for 10 years. It's buttery yellow and a modest two stories. The moldings and everything are very simple. And to my extreme delight, Bob and Larry knew all about Orson Fowler's Octagon theory of modern living. They had done nothing to change the structure of the house. It's actually intact from its original building, which they can date because they found an inscription on the wall of their kitchen. And if you look at it, it says Stockport, Columbia County, November 9th, day 1860, a clear cool day Lincoln Abraham elected. And this was written on what was the original faux finish on the windows.
最终，对鲍勃和拉里来说，好处大于成本。就像偶然或侥幸或运气一样，八角屋作为一种技术或多或少对他们有效。在建筑上，鲍勃和拉里正在实践福勒的八面愿景。光线是有益的这种想法，我们知道那是真的。
So we know the house predates 1860. Wow. That's really cool. That's really cool. That's really cool. Bob and Larry's living room slash dining room is functionally one massive undivided parlor. And you can see the light stream in from all eight corners of the house across the course of the day.
空气循环是有益的。鲍勃说，如果他们在夏日打开门，微风会穿过房子，循环得非常好。自从住进这所房子以来，鲍勃和拉里自己也开始种植果树。桃子、苹果和樱桃，过去几年，因为健康问题，我不太活跃。但在那之前，我会相当定期地
Their parlor is lush, full of thriving plants and even some bonsai trees that Bob cultivates. Maybe it's parametric pressure, maybe it's light, but we could take a broomstick and stick it in dirt and it'll sprout. I mean, everything grows in here. I don't know what it is, but we rarely lose a plant. Granted, a downside of living in the octagon is that a lot of Bob and Larry's closets are weirdly
罐装保存。你是说你从阅读福勒的书里得到了种果树的想法吗？嗯，大部分作物的历史都来自房子。来自房子。我喜欢这个。他们不是从书里学到的。他们是从房子里学到的。拥有足够的空间和光线真好。它清空了我的思绪。这太棒了。有时我们只是坐在这里，拉里身体状况很差，但我们仍然告诉对方，
shaped and small. You can see that the closets are triangular. Yeah, here's a supply closet. You've made great use of this though. It's a very strange space. Yeah, but you know we're strange people. It's a very strange space. Yeah, but you know we're strange people. Ultimately, the benefits outweigh the cost for Bob and Larry. It's like by accident or by fluke or by luck, the Octagon House as a technology more or less worked for them. Architecturally, Bob and Larry are living Fowler's eight-sided vision. The thought that light was beneficial, we know that's true.
你知道，我们能忍受对方这么久是多么幸运。你知道，我们喜欢说，你知道，我们为了孩子，或者为了面子，或者任何类似的事情而在一起。你知道，我们在一起是因为我们想在一起。我们玩得很开心。房子对我们有好处。虽然，鲍勃和拉里可以学会住在改建的白色城堡里。
Air circulation being beneficial. Bob says if they leave the door open on a summer day, a breeze runs through the house and it circulates very well. And since living in the house, Bob and Larry themselves began planting fruit trees. Peaches and apples and cherries for the last couple years, because of health issues, I've been less active. But before that, I would pretty regularly
空气流通很有益处。鲍勃说，如果他们在夏日敞开大门，微风就会穿过房子，流通得非常好。自从住进这所房子，鲍勃和拉里就开始种植果树。桃树、苹果树和樱桃树。过去几年，因为健康问题，我没那么活跃了。但在那之前，我经常
can preserve. Were you saying you got the idea for the fruit trees from Reading Fowler's book? Well, most of the history of the crop is from the house. From the house. I love that. They didn't learn it from the book. They learned it from the house. It's nice having the amount of space and the amount of light. It clears my mind. It's great. Sometimes we just sit here and Larry is a very poor health, but we still tell each other,
可以做果酱。你是说你种果树的想法是从福勒的书里得来的吗？嗯，大部分关于作物的历史都是源自这所房子。源自这所房子。我喜欢这一点。他们不是从书里学到的。他们是从房子里学到的。拥有这么大的空间和充足的光线真好。这让我的头脑清醒。太棒了。有时我们只是坐在这里，虽然拉里的健康状况很差，但我们仍然会告诉对方，
you know, how lucky we are to be able to put up with each other all of this time. You know, we like to say, you know, we've staying together for the sake of the kids, or to show face, or anything like that. You know, we're with each other because we want to. We have a good time. And the house is good for us. Although, Bob and Larry could learn to live in a converted white castle.
你知道，我们能在一起这么久是多么幸运。你知道，我们喜欢说，我们在一起是为了孩子，或者是为了面子之类的。你知道，我们在一起是因为我们想在一起。我们过得很开心。这所房子对我们很有好处。虽然，鲍勃和拉里也可以学着住在改造过的白色城堡里。
Yeah, I mean, I would never say that the octagon house is an idea that we should revive today because it's a great way of building. But I think they're really interesting to think about just because they are so eccentric. I'm really interested in what compels people to actually adopt the idea for a time. What I've realized is that over and over again, when culture is shifting and values are changing
是的，我的意思是，我绝不会说八角屋是我们今天应该复兴的一种理念，因为它是一种伟大的建筑方式。但我认为它们非常值得思考，仅仅因为它们太古怪了。我真的很感兴趣是什么促使人们在一段时间内真正采纳了这个想法。我意识到的是，一次又一次，当文化在转变，价值观在改变时，
and people are looking for new ways of living, that's when vernacular design reaches beyond the square. All those domes and urits and octagons were all full of promise and new ideas. And, sure, you could call them fads, but that's sort of writing them off. I think the thing about fads is they're short-lived, but they also point to the possibility of sudden shifts in culture and rapid changes in attitude. The hallmark of a fad is that it goes away quickly, that it didn't last, that it failed. But Professor Chang says what's really interesting about a fad
人们在寻找新的生活方式，这就是乡土设计超越方形的时候。所有的那些圆顶、尤里特（urits）和八角形都充满了希望和新思想。当然，你可以称它们为时尚，但这有点否定了它们。我认为时尚的特点是它们寿命短，但它们也指向了文化突然转变和态度迅速改变的可能性。时尚的标志是它消失得很快，它没有持续下去，它失败了。但张教授说，关于时尚真正有趣的是
is how it starts. It's capacity to take off so quickly. There's power in understanding what gets so many people on board with something new and radical. And, you know, for somebody who's interested in the possibility of meaningful change, it's interesting sometimes to study the techniques of dissemination and like what were the techniques of persuasion that compelled people to try something different and try something new. Because homes, by their very nature of being homey, are supposed to be familiar.
它是如何开始的。它能如此迅速地起飞的能力。理解是什么让这么多人接受某种新的、激进的东西是有力量的。而且，你知道，对于那些对有意义的变革的可能性感兴趣的人来说，有时研究传播技巧是很有趣的，比如是什么样的说服技巧促使人们尝试不同的东西，尝试新的东西。因为家，就其本身而言，应该是熟悉的。
They're supposed to be what we already know. And something about the octagon shape, something about breaking out of the literal box, seemed to liberate the people who interacted with them. The octagon seemed to provide the space for inhabitants to break their own molds, to try on new lifestyles, by canning their own peaches or restoring a sphinx piano or hell taking this radical structure and filling it up with collections of colonial t-sets. The Colonial Dame Museum inside of an octagon house is the biggest manifestation of a square pagan around hole that I've ever seen
它们应该是我们已经知道的东西。关于八角形的某种东西，关于打破字面意义上的盒子，似乎解放了与它们互动的人。八角形似乎为居住者提供了打破自身模具的空间，尝试新的生活方式，比如自己罐装桃子，或者修复斯芬克斯钢琴，或者天哪，拿着这种激进的结构，用殖民时期的茶具收藏填满它。八角屋里的殖民地女士博物馆是我见过的最大的方钉圆孔的体现，
look architecturally. That square pagan and octagon on the floor. I just kind of, and I love it. So thank you so much for coming with me. Coming up after the break, octagon houses don't just have a lot of fresh air and sunlight. They also have a lot of ghosts. Avery tries to convince me after this. So, hi, Roman. Hey, Avery.
从建筑上看。那个方钉和地板上的八角形。我只是，我喜欢它。所以非常感谢你和我一起来。休息后回来，八角屋不仅有很多新鲜空气和阳光。它们还有很多鬼魂。艾弗里在之后试图说服我。那么，嗨，罗曼。嘿，艾弗里。
Are you sold on the idea of living in an octagon house? I mean, not even remotely, actually. Oh, really? I mean, the light, the air. I think the light and the air and stuff would all be very beautiful. And you met lots of really fun people, and I wish to be included amongst the fun people who would live in an octagon house. Sure.
你被住在八角屋的想法说服了吗？我的意思是，甚至一点都没有，实际上。哦，真的吗？我的意思是，光线，空气。我认为光线和空气之类的东西会非常美丽。而且你会遇到很多非常有趣的人，我希望被列入那些会住在八角屋的有趣的人之中。当然。
And so yes, I guess I'm actually more sold than my cynical first take would tell you. But being inside the one with you in San Francisco was actually quite lovely. I enjoyed it. And that's the thing. That was like a museum renovated octagon house. Like going into an actual home, it is kind of incredible.
所以是的，我想我实际上比我愤世嫉俗的第一印象所说的更容易被说服。但和你一起在旧金山的那间房子里实际上相当可爱。我很享受。这就是重点。那就像是一个博物馆翻新的八角屋。就像走进一个真正的家，这真是太不可思议了。
I mean, there's all this space in its got to the slide. And honestly, after going to all these Octagon houses, I was like, I'm pretty soul, especially after seeing Bob and Larry. I was like, I'm pretty soul. This looks pretty nice. But if you are considering moving into an Octagon-shaped house,
我的意思是，它有所有的空间，它有滑梯。老实说，在去了所有这些八角屋之后，我想，我被说服了，特别是在看到鲍勃和拉里之后。我想，我被说服了。这看起来很不错。但如果你正在考虑搬进一个八角形的房子，
you should be warned that it is probably haunted. Okay. Do you feel like there are notable differences living in an octagon house? With a light for one. And the ghosts. The ghosts. Oh.
你应该被警告，它很可能是闹鬼的。好的。你觉得住在八角屋有什么显著的区别吗？光线是一个。还有鬼魂。鬼魂。哦。
First the light, then the ghosts. What about the light? So I shouldn't say that all octagon houses are haunted. I can't speak for all octagon houses, but I have to say when I was beginning to research the story, I was like, surely other people must have made podcasts about Octagon houses. And I looked around and they were all like ghost hunting podcasts. At first, I was like, oh, you know, whatever, anyone thinks anything's haunted. But Bob and Larry specifically are not normally the ghost hunting types.
先是光线，然后是鬼魂。光线怎么样？我不应该说所有的八角屋都闹鬼。我不能代表所有的八角屋，但我不得不说，当我开始研究这个故事时，我想，肯定有其他人制作过关于八角屋的播客。我环顾四周，它们都是关于捉鬼的播客。起初，我想，哦，你知道，随便吧，任何人都会认为任何东西闹鬼。但鲍勃和拉里特别不是那种捉鬼的人。
Are you ghost people? No. I was like, I could capture your face. And neither is Michael Lombardi at the Armor Steiner House. Is it haunted? It is. There is a ghost. Yep. And I'm not a big ghost proponent or you know I'm not running around talking about ghosts, but there is absolutely a ghost here, the octagon house. Like you felt it? I have felt it, I have smelled it.
你们是捉鬼的人吗？不。我想，我可以捕捉你的脸。迈克尔·隆巴迪在阿莫尔·施泰纳故居也不是。它闹鬼吗？是的。有一个鬼魂。是的。我不是一个大的鬼魂支持者，或者你知道，我不是到处谈论鬼魂，但这里绝对有一个鬼魂，八角屋。就像你感觉到了？我感觉到了，我闻到了。
She comes in the form of floral scent, of lilacs, yep. So Orson Fowler had nothing about like guaranteed ghosts or anything, but octagons do seem to attract a certain kind of like genre of ghost, which is to say playful with bizarre but generally okay vibes. She's mischievous. She's done things that I can't explain. My father has a couple of ones early on. He was trying to open up a window that was painted shut and he couldn't
她以花香的形式出现，丁香花的味道，是的。所以奥森·福勒（Orson Fowler）对保证有鬼魂之类的东西一无所知，但八角形似乎确实吸引了某种类型的鬼魂，也就是说，顽皮、古怪但总体上氛围还可以。她很淘气。她做了一些我无法解释的事情。我父亲早年有几次经历。他试图打开一扇被油漆封死的窗户，但他无法
get the window open and he kept rattling and moving it. And so he went to go to the kitchen to get a knife or screwdriver or something and when he came back, the window was wide open. Ah, there's more. I was giving a tour of about 20 people and I was telling the ghost story that she comes in the form of a Lylex sent and she's kind of mischievous and somebody said I smell Lylex and there is some chocolate and then another person said I smell Lylex and then another person said I smell Lylex and then everyone got really quiet and It was like the tour was over and everybody just walked carefully out of the house and that was it.
打开窗户，他不停地摇晃和移动它。所以他去厨房拿刀或螺丝刀之类的东西，当他回来时，窗户大开了。啊，还有更多。我当时正在给大约20个人做导览，我正在讲那个鬼故事，说她以丁香花香的形式出现，她有点淘气，有人说我闻到了丁香花味，还有一些巧克力味，然后另一个人说我闻到了丁香花味，然后又一个人说我闻到了丁香花味，然后每个人都变得非常安静，就像导览结束了，每个人都小心翼翼地走出了房子，就是这样。
I love it. And then Bob and Larry really have a definitive handle on who their ghost is. They've kept articles from local papers about the haunted octagon house and they think their ghost is a member of the original family that built the house. That makes sense. The Smith family, it seems, we're still living with it. The fourth child, the daughter that we know of is Rachel and she shows up every once in a while. How does she appear? Tell her about the... Oh, the cocktail party. That's probably the best story because we had...
我喜欢它。然后鲍勃和拉里确实对他们的鬼魂是谁有明确的掌握。他们保留了当地报纸关于闹鬼八角屋的文章，他们认为他们的鬼魂是建造这座房子的原始家庭的一员。这说得通。史密斯一家，看来，我们仍然和它住在一起。我们知道的第四个孩子，女儿是瑞秋，她偶尔会出现。她是怎么出现的？告诉她关于……哦，鸡尾酒会。那可能是最好的故事，因为我们有……
How many witnesses? Like six people here, and we're sitting, we're drinking, and one of our friends, Louise, who is Colombian, who is a very deep voice. And in Colombia, there are spirits everywhere, have it handling. She says, Ladi, have you heard from your ghost lately on
多少目击者？大概六个人在这里，我们坐着，我们喝着酒，我们的一个朋友，路易丝，她是哥伦比亚人，声音很低沉。在哥伦比亚，到处都是灵魂，有处理方法。她说，拉里，你最近听到你的鬼魂了吗？
you footsteps loud as day across the ceiling from one side to the other? Everyone looked up, snapped up, followed the footsteps across the ceiling and then everyone looked at me and I said, does that answer your question?
脚步声响亮如天，穿过天花板从一边到另一边？每个人都抬头看，猛地抬头，跟着脚步声穿过天花板，然后每个人都看着我，我说，这回答了你的问题吗？
Oh my God. Bob and Larry hear footsteps a lot and they said in the night, sometimes they feel like a weight on the bed. Like the cat has jumped in bed with them, but the cat's not near the bed. And you might be like, oh, well, you know, they're old, they're old, creaky buildings. And like the wind comes through in funky ways. But Larry used to keep a shelf with glassware in his office. And one day when Larry was in the kitchen and Bob was out in the front room,
天哪。鲍勃和拉里经常听到脚步声，他们说在晚上，有时他们觉得床上有一种重量。就像猫跳上了床，但猫不在床边。你可能会说，哦，好吧，你知道，它们是古老的、吱吱作响的建筑。风以奇怪的方式吹进来。但拉里过去常在他的办公室里放一个放玻璃器皿的架子。有一天，当拉里在厨房，鲍勃在前厅时，
we hear bang and a martini glass exploded. Exploded it. It didn't fall off. It had been there. It wasn't like newly cleaned or it was just sitting there like every other glass was sitting there. Doesn't this scare you? Not at all. Everyone who was on a free-state tom with Rachel. And you know, people that come here always say the house has such a good vibe to it. And I think that's Rachel.
我们听到砰的一声，一个马提尼杯爆炸了。爆炸了。它没有掉下来。它一直在那里。它不是刚清洗过的，它只是坐在那里，就像其他所有的杯子一样坐在那里。这不吓人吗？一点也不。每个在自由州汤姆（free-state tom）的人都和瑞秋在一起。你知道，来这里的人总是说房子有一种很好的氛围。我想那是瑞秋。
Hmm, let's wait. I think it's Bob and Larry, who makes the good vibe. We why? Well, they just seem humble and of good spirits and very kind and make a warm place. And that includes a warm welcome to Rachel as well. But. Do you buy it? Do you think the ghosts are real?
嗯，等等。我认为是鲍勃和拉里，他们创造了良好的氛围。我们为什么？好吧，他们看起来很谦虚，精神很好，非常善良，创造了一个温暖的地方。这包括对瑞秋的热烈欢迎。但是。你相信吗？你认为鬼魂是真的吗？
Well, okay. So, I don't think they're real, but I enjoy people enjoying their homes and enjoying stories and enjoying laughing and having dinner parties with baritone Colombians who conjure ghosts. I love all that. And so, it doesn't matter what I really believe,
好吧，好的。所以，我不认为它们是真的，但我喜欢人们享受他们的家，享受故事，享受欢笑，并与男中音的哥伦比亚人共进晚餐，他们召唤鬼魂。我喜欢这一切。所以，我真正相信什么并不重要，
I like it as a story. I don't have. No. No. It was just funny, like, thinking about the Octagon house, I was like, oh, I feel like the apartment I live in is probably very old and presumably lots of people have lived in here.
我喜欢把它作为一个故事。我没有。不。不。这只是很有趣，就像，想到八角屋，我想，哦，我觉得我住的公寓可能非常古老，大概很多人住在这里。
And the Octagon just sort of, by very nature of its different nists points out the things that are actually quite normal about houses. We're like, oh, like light air, aren't they great? Like, the history, it's so cool that like this house has had many lives and was like constructed by someone who had dreams and goals in a way they wanted to live.
八角形只是因为其不同角落的本质，指出了房子里实际上非常正常的事情。我们就像，哦，像光线空气，它们不是很好吗？就像，历史，这座房子经历了很多生命，并且是由一个有梦想和目标的人建造的，这很酷，他们想要一种生活方式。
But in a weird way, just the shape of it announces itself. Like you can see the hand of intention. Exactly. And I feel like that lends itself better to ghosts. I think you put your finger on it, which is it is a shape and an intention therefore it concentrates spectral activity. Or you could say it concentrates stories and thinking about the past. But this is a place that screams for that kind of attention. And it is a place where you kind of know your part of history when you're in it, even when it was just being built.
但在某种奇怪的方式上，它的形状本身就宣告了它的存在。就像你可以看到意图的手。正是如此。我觉得这更适合鬼魂。我想你指出了这一点，那就是它是一个形状和一个意图，因此它集中了光谱活动。或者你可以说它集中了故事和对过去的思考。但这是一个呼唤这种关注的地方。这是一个当你身处其中时，你会知道你是历史的一部分的地方，即使在它刚被建造的时候。
They knew. Totally. And that carries forward to today. And so everything becomes a story. Everything gets wrapped up in a story. And a ghost story wraps up a ton of things, you know? It really is a nice basket to hold history. And that's why I like ghost stories a lot, even though I'm not really a believer in ghosts.
他们知道。完全正确。这延续到了今天。所以一切都变成了一个故事。一切都被包裹在一个故事里。而一个鬼故事包裹了很多东西，你知道吗？它确实是一个容纳历史的好篮子。这就是为什么我非常喜欢鬼故事，即使我并不是一个真正的鬼魂信徒。
Well, thanks so much for telling us stories and coming back on 9% of Israel. It was real pleasure to have you. Oh, yeah, of course. I'm just your friendly ghost on ten Europe's Eurek Place. 99% of Israel was produced this week by A.E. Free Truffman. It was edited by Delaney Hall, fact-checking by Sona Avekin, mixed in tech production
好吧，非常感谢你告诉我们故事并回到99%的以色列（99% Invisible）。很高兴有你。哦，是的，当然。我只是你友好的鬼魂，在十欧罗巴广场（ten Europe's Eurek Place）。99%的以色列本周由A.E. Free Truffman制作。由Delaney Hall编辑，Sona Avekin事实核查，混音和技术制作
by Martin Gonzales. Production assistance by Jacob Maldonado Medina and Sarah Baker, music by director of Sound Swan Rial. Special thanks to Alison C. Meyer and Rebecca LeWin McArley, who was so helpful with research for this story, also thanks to Meredith Hotenot, Drew Hopped, Joy Eusson, and most of all, to Zach Fischman. 99% of visible is executive producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colestet is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmet Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashmodon, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker,
由Martin Gonzales完成。制作助理Jacob Maldonado Medina和Sarah Baker，音乐由声音总监Swan Rial负责。特别感谢Alison C. Meyer和Rebecca LeWin McArley，她们对这个故事的研究非常有帮助，也感谢Meredith Hotenot, Drew Hopped, Joy Eusson，最重要的是，感谢Zach Fischman。99%的以色列执行制片人是Delaney Hall。Kurt Colestet是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Emmet Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashmodon, Jason Dillion, Sophia Klatsker,
and me Roman Mars. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Series XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. So I'm, this is, this is new since I've been here.
还有我，罗曼·马斯。99%的以色列是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI org。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有。你可以在99PI dot org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI的每一集过去的内容。所以我，这是，这是我在这里以来的新内容。
How do you do the stitcher stings? So we kind of like figure them out, like kind of at the last minute. It's like the last thing we do on the show at all. So, do you have any ideas? Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh No! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是怎么做Stitcher的片尾的？所以我们有点像是在最后一刻才想出来的。这就像我们在节目中做的最后一件事。所以，你有什么想法吗？不！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。